beginnen wir mit einer Frage könnte der
Krieg in der Ukraine zu einer Hungersnot
in Afrika führen
vielleicht schon einigen von euch die
Frage weiter hergeholt denn Russland und
die Ukraine liegen am östlichen Rand
Europas und elender Afrikas tausende
Kilometer weit von ihnen entfernt aber
meine Lieben Zuschauer der russische
Krieg in der Ukraine hat die Welt auf
den Kopf gestellt oft haben wir euch
davon erzählt welches Chaos er an den
Energiemärkten verursacht hat doch Öl
und Gas sind nicht die einzigen
Betroffenen Rohstoffe Weizen und Mais
sind es auch der Agrarmarkt geriet durch
den Krieg also ebenfalls ins Wanken denn
ausgerechnet bei Russland oder Ukraine
handelt es sich um zwei der größten
Agrarproduzenten der Welt und auch wir
alle spüren es in unserem Alltag der
Gang zum Bäcker zum Fleischer und zum
Supermarkt ist im vergangenen Jahr
deutlich teurer geworden das ist extrem
hart für viele Menschen mit kleinen
Portemonnaie aber immerhin hier in
Europa und in den USA geht es nicht
unbedingt um massenhaftes verhungern in
Afrika jedoch sieht es anders aus ganz
anders
wir haben euch hier auf visualpolitik
schon oft erzählt wie viele Fortschritte
gemacht werden beim Kampf gegen den
Welthunger und tatsächlich schienen ist
eine Weile so als sein große Hungersnöte
endgültig besiegt der russische und der
ukrainische Agrarsektor haben bei diesen
Erfolgen eine Schlüsselrolle gespielt um
euch eine Vorstellung davon zu gehen die
Ukraine produziert jedes Jahr genug
Lebensmittel für 400 Millionen Menschen
und viele davon leben im Afrikas südlich
der Sahara jetzt aber hat der russische
Krieg alles viel schwieriger gemacht
auch für diese Leute fakt ist die
Getreideexporte aus der Ukraine und
Russland sind nicht mehr so groß und
zahlreiche wie vor Putins Überfall auf
sein Nachbarland und das liest die
Preise für Getreide an den Agrarmärkten
in die Höhe schießen der Grund hierfür
ist übrigens nicht nur das ukrainische
Hefen am Schwarzen Meer von Russland
angegriffen und blockiert werden und die
waren Abfertigung stockt oder dass die
Kämpfe die Produktion behindern nein
auch die Sanktion des Westens erschweren
und verteuern den Export der begehrten
Agrargüter aus Russland das Ergebnis die
wahrscheinlich irgendeiner Hungersnot
ist in Afrika so hoch wie seit den
1980er Jahren nicht mehr vor allem in
den Ländern der seilzone am Südrand der
Sahara die Frage lautet also was tut die
Welt um solch ein Szenario zu verhindern
warum sind die afrikanischen Länder
überhaupt so abhängig von Russland und
der Ukraine und wir haben noch zwei
weitere Fragen die euch vielleicht noch
mehr überraschen werden welche Rolle
spielt die Türkei in dieser ganzen
Geschichte kann das Land am Bosporus
vielleicht sogar der Retter der
Afrikaner vor dem Hunger werden all
diese Fragen werden wir in diesem Video
beantworten nach der kurzen Botschaft
unseres Träumen Sponsors zu Aufschlag
der es mit seinem Beitrag möglich
gemacht hat surfshark hat nämlich auch
ein VPN im Angebot das wirklich
empfehlenswert und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt es zum
Beispiel selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kann ein
virtualitativ
lauern man muss nach wie vor Umsicht
halten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es steht hier für ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert ist in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen letzten
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören die Bilder
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eine limitiert im Netz erhöhen
zum Beispiel mit dem integrierten
klimberg das alle unerwünschten Cookies
und Popups blockt weiterer Vorteil ist
dass ihr so tun könnt als wäre die an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auch
Webseite und Internetdienste zugreifen
in dem Land den ich gerade nicht
verfügbar werden ob daheim oder auch
verreisen damit schlagt die Zensur und
blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
andere Streaming diese Inhalte anbieten
von Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
Surfer kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles denn wenn du alles
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte im VPN
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt
auch noch eine Rabatt in Höhe von 83%
und obendrein die ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nichts wie du es
besorgt gerade damit auch gleichzeitig
uns finanzielle unter die Arme das
könnte übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe
der Spenden links ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hättet ihr uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun wieder zum Risiko
einer durch den russischen Angriffskrieg
induzierten hungerskrise wie so oft
erleichtert ein Blick in die Geschichte
das Verständnis dieses Systems also
aufgepasst
Technologie Produktivität und harter
Arbeit
wir haben es auf visualpolitik schon oft
erwähnt die Zahl der Menschen die an
Hunger leiden ist in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten stark zurückgegangen in
diesem Jahrhundert ist extremer Hunger
also er selten und das hat vor allem
einen Grund technischen Fortschritt bei
Wirtschaftswachstum und Innovation
denken wir oft an die IT-Industrie
Software das Internet und so weiter doch
auch die Agrarindustrie hat enorme
Entwicklungssprünge hingelegt wenn auch
etwas im Schatten von Google Facebook
oder Amazon zu Beginn des 20
Jahrhunderts gab es in Europa oder
Nordamerika noch bilder wie diese doch
heute innen die Felder der am meisten
entwickelten Länder immer mehr diesen
Welt genau es ist immer häufiger zu
sehen wie Hightech die Felder bestellt
und die Ernte einfährt da Düsen
fahrerlose Traktoren über die Felder
bewässerungsroboter versorgen die
Pflanzen und Drohnen schweben über den
Äckern all diese Technik macht die
Landwirtschaft viel effizienter und
ermöglicht uns jedes Jahr mehr
Lebensmittel zu produzieren doch nicht
nur die Geräte für die
Pflanzenproduktion werden besser auch
Düngung und sogar die Pflanzen selbst
gentechnisch verändert und auf optimalen
abgezüchte tragen auch Sie zu neuen
produktionsrekorden bei der erste große
Sprung nach vorn ist in der
Landwirtschaft schon vor vielen
Jahrzehnten gelungen und zwar ab der
zweiten Hälfte des vorigen Jahrhunderts
mit der sogenannten grünen Revolution
[Musik]
aber keine Angst die Grünen in Berlin
haben damit nicht zu tun sie wären auch
eher dagegen gewesen die grüne
Revolution von der wir hier sprechen
waren nichts anderes als eine
gigantische Steigerung der weltweiten
landwirtschaftlichen Produktivität sie
begann Ende der 1950er Jahre in Mexiko
und den Vereinigten Staaten mit der
weißen Revolution und breitete sich
allmählich über den ganzen Globus aus
die Produktivitätssteigerung kam durch
den Einsatz neue Technologien zustande
durch neue Getreidesorten die resistent
waren gegen extremes Wetter und gegen
bestimmte Schädlinge auch der Einsatz
synthetischer dünner und neuer
Pflanzenschutzmittel Druck zu besseren
Erträgen bei davon profitierten Länder
in Lateinamerika und ganz Asien Länder
wie Mexiko Pakistan Indien konnten ihre
Produktion vervielfachen
[Musik]
ein weiteres bekanntes Beispiel ist
China auch das profitierte extrem stark
von der grünen Revolution und zusammen
mit den marktwirtschaftlichen Reformen
denks konnte man dort die Zahl der
Hungersnöte auf einen historischen
Tiefstand zurückdrängen man könnte sagen
dass die grüne Revolution so manchen
maltesianer zum Nachdenken brachte was
maltosianer sind nun es sind die
Anhänger einer bestimmten Denkrichtung
die glauben dass das
Bevölkerungswachstum der Grund sei für
Ressourcen Knappheit in der Welt sie
schlussfolgern daraus man müsste die
Zahl der Menschen begrenzen sie klammern
dabei aber oft aus wie technologischer
Fortschritt erschafft mehr Menschen zu
versorgen die Gründer Revolution hat
bewiesen das Fortschritte in der
Landwirtschaft ein hohes
Bevölkerungswachstum aufwiegen und den
Hunger besiegen können und nicht nur das
die Revolution widerlegte auch ein
anderes Vorurteil von Fortschritt
Skeptikern diese glauben um eine höhere
Produktionsrate in der Landwirtschaft zu
erreichen müssten angeblich mehr
Menschen im Agrarsektor arbeiten aber in
Wahrheit ist das Gegenteil der Fall
wie ihr seht arbeiten immer weniger
Menschen in diesem Sektor während die
Produktion gleichzeitig steigt aber es
gibt Regionen auf der Welt in denen die
grüne Revolution praktisch ausbieten
eine davon ist das
afrikaarmsytrant der Sahara aber warum
eigentlich
nun aus mehreren Gründen der erste und
vielleicht wichtigste Grund ist dass
viele dieser Länder noch um ihre
Unabhängigkeit kämpften während andere
während der grünen Revolution bereits
unabhängig waren okay viele werden jetzt
anwenden dass Unabhängigkeit von der
einstigen Kolonialmacht doch etwas Gutes
ist aber leider erfolgte oft darauf eine
sehr turbulente Zeit und es ging abwärts
mit diesen freien Ländern es kam zu
schweren jahrzehntelangen Macht kämpfen
den neuen Eliten korruptionblüte auf
alles keine guten Voraussetzungen für
Investitionen Infrastrukturprojekte und
produktivere Landwirtschaft allerdings
ist das noch nicht alles ja Mangel an
Infrastruktur ist auch einer der Gründe
warum der Düngemittel Einsatz in dieser
Region so gering ist die Transportkosten
sind dort einfach viel höher und die
dort ansässigen Bauern können es sich
aus diesem Gründen nicht leisten Dünger
und Pflanzenschutzmittel zu vertretbaren
Preisen auf ihre Felder zu schaffen
hinzu kommen noch die extrem
klimatischen Bedingungen in den Gebieten
des subsahara Region Afrikas kurz um wir
haben es mit einem perfekten Cocktail zu
tun der Fortschritte in der dortigen
Landwirtschaft verhindert und deswegen
herrscht dort noch immer
Subsistenzlandwirtschaft vor soll heißen
die Menschen produzieren zum größten
Teil für sich selbst es handelt sich um
eine reine selbstversorgerwirtschaft die
uns eher an mittelalterliche Zustände
erinnert das Problem selbst das reicht
dort längst nicht für alle solch einer
Subsistenzwirtschaft ist nicht gerade
effizient die Länder müssen also
zusätzliche Lebensmittel importieren für
eine Bevölkerung die immer weiter wächst
deswegen ist die Abhängigkeit dieser
Länder vom Ausland mit dem
Bevölkerungswachstum überproportional
gestiegen und mit der Zeit ist das Ganze
zu einer Artikel der ZEIT Bombe geworden
die nun mit den Beginn des Krieges in
der Ukraine Plaste denn für Afrika sind
ausgerechnet Russland und die Ukraine
Länder von denen sie am meisten abhängig
sind wenn es uns tägliche Brot geht okay
dieser Zusammenhang sollte allen klar
sein aber das ganze ist leider noch ein
wenig komplexer schauen wir uns in
diesem Zusammenhang deswegen mal genauer
an was das Ganze eigentlich mit den
internationalen Finanzmärkten zu tun hat
aufgepasst
[Musik]
finanzielle Innovationen gegen den
Hunger
erinnert ihr euch noch an die
Globalisierungsgegner das waren
sogenannte Aktivisten wie Occupy Wall
Street zum Beispiel Anfang der 2010er
Jahre behaupteten sie dass die
weltweiten Finanzmärkte die Dritte Welt
völlig zerstören und dass die
Unterschied zwischen reichen und armen
Ländern katastrophal zunehmen würden nun
wie sich mittlerweile herausgestellt hat
könnte nichts weiter von der Wahrheit
entfernt sein denn neben der technischen
Entwicklung haben auch die Finanzmärkte
dazu beigetragen den Hunger auf der Welt
zu reduzieren wir sprechen hier ganz
speziell über den sogenannten
Terminmarkt für Agrarprodukte das sind
vereinfacht gesagt Handelsplätze also
Börsen auf denen man landwirtschaftliche
Produkte wie beides oder meist kaufen
und verkaufen kann aber ohne dass diese
waren dort vor Ort lagern müssen und man
muss sie auch nicht bei jeder
Transaktion von A nach B transportieren
die Händler auf diesen Märkten handeln
nur mit Papieren bzw digitalen Kontakten
deren Gegenstand ist es in Zukunft einen
bestimmten Rohstoff wie Weizen oder
meist zu liefern bzw diesen Rohstoff
abzunehmen es sind sogenannte waren
Termingeschäfte die gehandelten Kontakte
heißen Futures denn sie beziehen sich
auf eine zukünftige warentransaktion der
Verkäufer eines Futures verpflichtet
sich zu einer Lieferung eines Rohstoffs
und der Käufer zu einem Kauf natürlich
kann ein solcher future-kontrakt bis zum
erfüllungstag immer wieder gehandelt
werden um den Besitzer wechseln aber das
Grundprinzip ist folgendes ein Anbieter
von z.B weißen kann sich für den
künftigen verkaufter Ware schon vorab
Verkaufspreise sichern das gibt dem
Agrarproduzenten Sicherheit und jetzt
mögen Begriffe wie Futures total
neumodisch klingen aber solche Geschäfte
gibt es schon seit dem 19 Jahrhundert
der erste landwirtschaftliche
Terminmarkt wurde 1848 in den USA an der
chicagober board of Trader eröffnet
einer Börse die heute noch aktiv ist
aber erst in den 1960ern und 70er Jahren
entwickelte sich ein wirklich globaler
und freier Markt für den Kauf und
Verkauf von Agrarprodukten und das
belegte die Landwirtschaft ungemein denn
nun konnte man grenzenlos schon lange
vor der Lieferung Geschäfte abschließen
mittels der Future Geschäfte konnte man
schon lange vor der tatsächlichen Ernte
und dem Transporte auf der einen Seite
die Finanzierung sichern und auf der
anderen die Versorgung sich erstellen
und diese Planungssicherheit bedeutet
für alle dann auch höhere Profite und
wir alle wissen wo profitabel Geld
fließt wirkt es wie Dünger es belebt die
Investitionen die Wirtschaft kann
wachsen und genau das geschah in der
Landwirtschaft Produktion und Handeln
mit Weizen Mais und allen anderen
möglichen Agrargütern Namen zu wie stark
könnt ihr in folgender Übersicht sehen
[Musik]
eine neuer globaler Markt Warburg dank
ihm hatten die Entwicklungsländer jetzt
die Chance günstig Nahrungsmittel
einzukaufen die sie selbst nur schwer
und unwirtschaftlich produzieren konnten
auch die Länder Afrikas in denen die
grüne Revolution aussieht konnten so
ihre produktionsdefizite durch Käufer
auf dem internationalen Markt
kompensieren und tatsächlich reduzierte
dies dort die Zahl der Hungersnöte
völlig verschwunden sind sie aber nicht
z.B gibt es derzeit eine dramatische
Hungersnot in Somalia der Grund ist eine
anhaltende Dürre mehr als 43.000
Menschen vielen ihr bereits zum Opfer
aber trotzdem genannten Chance
Lebensmittel international zu günstigen
Preis zu kaufen es bleibt das Risiko von
Preisschwankungen an den
nahrungsmittelmärkten es kann also
trotzdem immer noch vorkommen dass die
armen Länder teuer einkaufen müssen oder
sich dies überhaupt nicht leisten können
das haben wir zum Beispiel in der
Finanzkrise 2008 gesehen die auch zu
einer Nahrungsmittelkrise führte und
2020 haben wir es mit dem Lockdown
bedingten Zusammenbruch der Lieferketten
erneut erlebt der Punkt ist jetzt ist
Situation noch dramatischer Werft bitte
mal einen Blick auf jede Länder die
weltweit die größten getreideexporteure
sind
da haben wir es russland ist der größte
getreideexporter der Welt und die
Ukraine der fünftgrößte und wir reden
hier nicht nur über Getreide beide
Länder sind auch großexporteure viele
andere Agrarprodukte nehmen wir zum
Beispiel Sonnenblumenöl vor dem Krieg
hatte die Ukraine einen Weltmarktanteil
von 46% bei diesem Grundnahrungsmittel
ihrer nährstoffreichen schwarzböden und
ihre Formen seit dem Union haben dazu
geführt dass die beiden Länder zu den
Kornkammern des großen Teils Europas und
der Welt wurden Länder wie benennen
Tansania und Kongo importieren mehr als
70% ihres Getreides aus Russland die
Abhängigkeiten sind also immens wie
damals bei Öl und Gas für Europa nur mit
dem Unterschied dass die
hochentwickelten Industrieländer mit
Hilfe ihrer scheckbücher relativ schnell
gefunden haben diese Abhängigkeiten zu
kompensieren sowohl bei energiestoffen
als auch bei Lebensmitteln die Länder
Afrika sind hier naturgemäß sehr stark
eingeschränkt in ihren Möglichkeiten
weil sie arm und machtlos sind und genau
deswegen gefährdet der Krieg zwischen
Russland oder Ukraine die
Nahrungsmittelversorgung in der Welt die
Frage ist also was wird momentan um eine
drohende humanitäre Katastrophe in
Afrika zu verhindern wie wird versucht
die Preissteigerungen in den Griff zu
bekommen genau das schauen wir uns jetzt
mal an
[Musik]
die Stunde der Türken
in der Ukraine arbeiten rund 72% der
gesamten Landbevölkerung in der
Landwirtschaft der Krieg hat dem
Agrarsektor jedoch schwer zugesetzt
durch Bombardierung Zwangsrekrutierung
und die russische seherschaft im
Schwarzen Meer wurden Produktion und
handbehindert was zu einem Mangel an
Produkten führte und dadurch sind die
Preise in die Höhe geschossen außerdem
haben schätzungsweise 25% aller
ukrainischen Haushalte die von der
Landwirtschaft leben ihre Tätigkeit
eingestellt aber nicht nur die Ukraine
hat Probleme auch Russland ist nicht
verschont geblieben zwar haben die
westlichen Länder keine Sanktionen gegen
den Agrarsektor hängt sie schaden jedoch
indirektors Landwirtschaft es ist für
die großen jetzt viel schwerer
internationale Geschäfte abzuwickeln da
sie von internationalen Zahlungssystem
ausgeschlossen sind und ihre Logistik
sanktioniert wird und weil sich
Versicherer weigern den Transport
russischer Ladungen zu decken deswegen
leidet der russische Agrarsektor fast
ebenso schwer wie der ukrainische unter
dem Krieg sicherlich versteht ihr jetzt
was der Grund für die Preisanstiege ist
die in dieser Grafik seht und die
Auswirkungen konnte die auch zum
Beispiel beim Bäcker um die Ecke
bemerken wo Brot und Brötchen plötzlich
teurer wurden natürlich geht es nicht
nur um Brot es geht um den Großteil des
gesamten lebensmittelkorbs und was in
Europa oder den USA eine unangenehme
Preiserhöhung sein mag kann einen
bestimmten Ländern Afrika's schon eine
Hungersnot auslösen und genau aus diesem
Grund versuchte die internationale
Gemeinschaft solch ein Szenario zu
verhindern hierbei kam vor allem die
Türkei ins Spiel
[Musik]
die Rolle der Türkei in diesem Krieg
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland ist
man könnte sagen ambivalent ankara hat
Russland nicht direkt sanktioniert aber
auch nicht unterstützt immerhin ist man
ja immer noch NATO Mitglied die Türkei
hat auch sehr kriegswichtige Waffen an
die ukrainische Armee geliefert
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an die
türkischen Bayer Aktionen die voriges
Jahr den russischen Invasoren den Garaus
gemacht haben das Land versucht im
Allgemeinen aber eine eher neutrale
Rolle zu spielen oder zumindest so nach
außen auszusehen das Ziel ist sich als
Vermittler zwischen den beiden Ländern
zum Präsentieren das westasiatische Land
muss dafür auch seine geographische Lage
ausschließlich die Türkei am Schwarzen
Meer und kontrolliert die mehr Enge des
Bosporus es war für Erdogan die
Gelegenheit auf internationale Bühne als
wichtige Akteur zu glänzen und
vielleicht auch das eigene Image etwas
aufzupolieren man spielte also eine
Schlüsselrolle bei dem Versuch die
Getreideexporte aus dem Schwarzen Meer
wieder zu gewährleisten gemeinsam mit
den Vereinten Nationen trieb Erdogan das
getreideabkommen voran dadurch sollten
die Getreidepreise wieder sinken
inhaltlich vereinbarte man beim
getreideabkommen folgendes Russland
bombardiert keine ukrainischen Schiffe
mehr die Getreide aus dem Schwarzen Meer
transportieren man ermöglicht es der
Ukraine ihre Exporte über drei Häfen
abzuwickeln nämlich Odessa Channel und
die Türkei kontrolliert in Istanbul alle
Schiffe und Ladungen wenn ukrainische
Schiffe einen Auslaufen um zu verhindern
dass sie z.B Waffen transportieren das
Abkommen hatte zunächst erfolgt die
Preise sein
wie ihr sehen könnt sind sowohl die
Weizen als auch die Maispreise seit der
Unterzeichnung des Abkommens gefallen
allerdings gab und gibt es auch Momente
große Unsicherheit weil Russland stets
damit drohte es wolle des Abkommen
brechen und das hat dazu geführt dass
die Preise ab und zu wieder gestiegen
sind tatsache ist das Moskau diese
Initiative leider als Druckmittel
missbraucht und immer wieder herum
spielt was nach wie vor zu
Preisschwankungen führt der kleine nutzt
den Hebel die das getreideabkommen
geschaffen hat um Lockerungen bei den
Sanktionen zu erreichen als Putin zum
Beispiel im Juli 2022 das Abkommen
unterzeichnete galt dies nur für 4
Monate und im November verlängerte er er
ist netterweise auch nur um vier Monate
und dann am 18 März 2023 verlängerte er
erst nur noch für 60 Tage warum naja
wohl wieder eines der üblichen
russischen Machtspielchen um den
Welthunger als faustform zu behalten
wenn wir uns endgültige entscheiden das
Abkommen nicht innerhalb von 60 Tagen zu
verlängern sind wir bereit die in der
letzten Zeit hat die besonders
Bedürftigen afrikanischen
jede Menge kostenlos aus Russland an
diese Länder zu liefern Wladimir Putin
im März 2023 er droht also auf der einen
Seite mit Nichtverlängerung und erklärt
auf der anderen großzügig seinen
Bereitschaft zu kostenlosen Lieferungen
aber was meint ihr soll man sich auf
Putins Wort verlassen glaubt ihr er habe
irgendwas umsonst zu verschenken gerade
jetzt wo er dringend Geld für seinen
Krieg braucht also das entspricht ganz
und gar nicht seinem Wesen und auch
nicht dem sein es macht Apparats sie
wollen immer eine Gegenleistung sie
machen nichts umsonst
[Musik]
wir haben euch ja bereits von Russland
Strategie in Afrika erzählt und davon
dass die russische Söldnergruppe Wagner
ihre Dienste auch nicht unbedingt
uneigennützig anbietet es geht immer um
Goldgeld und macht aber selbst wenn
Russland das getreideabkommen Platzen
ließe und irgendwie selbstständig
Getreide an die armen Länder liefern
würde es dürfte dennoch zu einer
Verknappung kommen weil die Ukraine als
Produzent praktisch aus viele denn eine
Russland dass ich nicht mehr anders
Abkommen hält würde wohl kaum die
Seewege im Schwarzen Meer ukrainische
Getreideexporte offen halten die
ukrainische Getreideproduktion viele
also in jedem Fall für den Weltmarkt weg
und genau deswegen ist das Abkommen von
entscheidender Bedeutung zum einen um
die Preise auf den internationalen
Märkten einigermaßen niedrig zu halten
und zum anderen um eine neue
ernährungskatastrophe in den von Hunger
bedrohten Ländern zu verhindern Russland
ist mit seinen Machtspielchen beim
getreideabkommen nicht nur ein
Unsicherheitsfaktor für die Märkte und
damit die Preise es stellt auch eine
erhebliches Risiko im täglichen Leben
Hunderter Millionen von Menschen da das
sind im Moment also die Erwartungen für
2023 in einem Markt der bereits stark
unter Druck steht die weltweite
Getreideernte wird in der Saison
2022/23 um 2,2% sinken aber sicher ist
auch das nicht es kann auch noch weniger
sein und damit dann wirklich
Menschenleben kosten eines ist also Fakt
der russische Krieg in der Ukraine ist
so eng mit der Ernährungssituation und
anderen Ländern verbunden das im
schlimmsten Fall hungersnote ausgelöst
werden können wir bleiben deswegen an
der Materie eng dran um euch auf dem
laufenden zu halten aber an diesem Punkt
interessiert uns erstmal eure Meinung
glaubt ihr das Russland aus dem
getreideabkommen Aussteigen wird werden
wir wieder eine große
Nahrungsmittelkrise erleben welche
Lösungen seht ihr um die Situation zu
entschärfen wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt haben falls ja gibt
uns bitte ein Like Teil dieses Video mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hat dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
der Link dazu findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung mach's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]